und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marie taslomka guten Abend seit
heute Mittag wird in Potsdam wieder
verhandelt im Tarifkonflikt des
öffentlichen Diensts haben die
Schlichter ja letzte Woche einen
Kompromissvorschlag vorgelegt der wurde
von beiden Seiten immerhin als gute
Gesprächsgrundlage bewertet Bund und
Kommunen verhandeln seit Monaten mit
Verdi und dem Beamtenbund das ganze
begleitet von massiven Warnstreiks die
ersten drei Runden waren ja gescheitert
sollte der Versuch zur Schlichtung an
diesem Wochenende auch ohne Ergebnis
bleiben könnten die Gewerkschaften in
der Folge zu unbefristeten strecks
aufrufen Jan Meyer und Katrin Lindner
berichten
sie machen auch heute Mittag Druck aus
Sicht der Gewerkschaftsmitglieder vor
dem Verhandlungsort in Potsdam sind die
Arbeitgeber ihren Forderungen nicht weit
genug entgegengekommen den rund 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigten des öffentlichen
Dienstes von Bund und Kommunen macht
nicht nur die Inflation zu schaffen
unsere Auszubildende Stelle bekommen wir
nicht besetzt weil sie woanders wo
einfach auch mehr bekommen ich arbeite
in der Kita und
das der Personalmangel und der
fachkraftmangel ist einfach so enorm und
dann muss einfach müssen einfach bessere
Bedingungen geschaffen werden müssen
ständig Überstunden machen und die Teams
werden immer weiter runter reduziert und
das ist das Problem bei dem
Geschäft zeigen Sie bitte liebe
verhandlungsspiel auf der
Arbeitgeberseite dass die junge Menschen
schätzen dass sie die Kolleginnen in
ihrem in ihrem öffentlichen Dienst
schätzen Ausgangspunkt der Verhandlungen
ist die Empfehlung der Schlichter die
sieht einen Inflationsausgleich von 3000
€ vor ab März 2024 soll es 200 € mehr
geben anschließen sollen die Löhne noch
einmal um 5,5% mindestens aber um 340 €
steigen vorgeschlagen wird eine Laufzeit
von 24 Monaten die Empfehlung bedeutet
allein für die Kommunen einen
Mehraufwand von 17 Milliarden Euro die
Verhandlungsführer von Bund und Kommunen
waren unterschiedlich davon überzeugt
dass es zu einer Einigung kommt die
Zeiten sind sehr schwierig deswegen
müssen wir sie auch angemessen
alimentieren ich glaube das wird uns
auch heute gelingen ich bin jedenfalls
sehr zuversichtlich das sind
Größenordnungen die vorher nie da waren
sie wissen wir sind eine Vereinigung von
16 Landesverbänden wir haben die Kranken
damit an Bord den Nahverkehr die
Sparkassen da gibt es natürlich auch
unterschiedliche Interessenlagen und
deswegen haben wir eine relativ
schwierige Ausgangslage für Verdi Chef
Wernicke ist es ein Zwischenerfolg dass
die Schlichter zweistellige
Lohnerhöhungen für Geringverdiener
vorschlagen die Gewerkschaften wollen
aber weitere Verbesserungen etwa für
Teilzeitbeschäftigte und Azubis aber wir
sind entschlossen und gehen konstruktiv
in diese Gespräche hinein und hoffen
dass auf der Grundlage der
schlichtungsempfehlung Empfehlung eine
Verständigung möglich ist wir hoffen
eben dass die kommunalen Arbeitgeber
auch die Erkenntnis gewinnen dass jetzt
die Runde scheitern zu lassen und dann
in die Uhr Abstimmung und ein
flächendeckenden Arbeitskampf
einzutreten auch keine gute Alternative
wäre die Gewerkschaften signalisieren
Stärke und Entschlossenheit der letzte
bundesweite unbefristete Streik im
öffentlichen Dienst liegt immerhin 31
Jahre zurück ob es unter diesem Druck in
Potsdam zu einer Einigung kommt das ist
offen
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
hat seine eigentlich geplante USA-Reise
abgesagt stattdessen sitzt er zusammen
mit Außenministerin baerbock im
Krisenstab des Auswärtigen Amtes die
Lage im Sudan macht das erforderlich
deutsche Staatsbürger sollen dort
rausgeholt werden ein erster Anlauf dazu
war am Mittwoch gescheitert weil die
eigentlich zugesagte Feuerpause nicht
eingehalten wurde
dem ostafrikanischen Staat bekämpfen
sich zwei rivalisierende Militärs die
sich vor zwei Jahren noch gemeinsam an
die Macht geputscht hatten war Lords ist
der treffende Begriff für diese beiden
Männer die für ihren Machtkampf
Millionen Menschen in Geiselhaft nehmen
glückliche Gesichter heute Nachmittag in
der saudi-arabischen Hafenstadt didda
mehr als 150 saudische Diplomaten und
ausländische Staatsbürger aus mehreren
Nationen konnten den Sudan an Bord eines
saudischen Kriegsschiffs verlassen
gestern war ihr Autokonvoi begleitet von
tsunamesischen Armeeeinheiten in der
Hauptstadt cartoum zur Hafenstadt
bordsudan aufgebrochen 800 km die Nacht
hindurch
Armeechef albohan einer der beiden
Kriegsherren kündigte heute an er werde
auch die Ausreise anderer ausländischer
Staatsbürger erleichtern die verlässlich
solche Zusagen sind darüber berichten in
Berlin Außenministerin bärburg
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius und
Experten im Krisenstab der
Bundesregierung im Mittelpunkt
Vorkehrungen für eine möglichst sichere
Ausreise der Deutschen aus cartoon
treffen die Situation sei ernst so
Pistorius
die Zeit drängt ein bisschen ein
bisschen mehr und deswegen ist es gut
dass wir schnell noch mal den letzten
das letzte Lager Update machen und vor
allen Dingen um diejenigen kümmern die
sich die größten Sorgen machen um Ihren
Aufenthalt bzw die Beendigung desselben
die Sorgen sind berechtigt denn auch die
jüngste Feuerpause zwischen den zwei
rivalisierenden Militärs armee-chef
Boran und Milizenführer daglo hielt
nicht stattdessen erneut Explosionen und
Schusswechsel rund um den Flughafen hier
wird seit einer Woche besonders heftig
gekämpft gleich neben dem Flughafen am
Südufer des Blauen Nils befindet sich
das Hauptquartier der Armee gegenüber am
Nordufer die deutsche Botschaft
schwer bewaffnete Truppen der Dark
lomiliz die gegen die Armee kämpft haben
nach eigenen Angaben eine Zufahrtstraße
zum Flughafen unter ihre Kontrolle
gebracht im Telefoninterview mit den
Sender aller Rabea betonte ihr
Befehlshaber douglow er werde die
Ausreise von Ausländern über den
Flughafen nicht behindert Verhandlungen
zur Beilegung des Konflikts lehnen aber
beide Seiten ab Armee und die
rivalisierende Minis wollen bis zum Sieg
kämpfen unterdessen wird die
Versorgungslage für die Menschen im
Sudan täglich schlechter es fehlt an
Lebensmitteln Wasser Strom und Benzin
die Bürger sind verzweifelt
eine Seite kann diesen Krieg gewinnen es
gibt nur Zerstörung Gewalt Plünderung
im Nachbarland Chat wo bereits 20.000
Flüchtlinge angekommen sind bereiten
sich helfe des Welternährungsprogramms
auf einem massive Krise vor
Hülle Programme wir rechnen mit einem
Zustrom von mindestens 100.000 Menschen
vielleicht werden es auch viel mehr
mindestens 400 Menschen starben nach
UN-Angaben bislang in den Kämpfen die
tatsächliche Opferzahl dürfte aber weit
höher liegen
ein Sonderflug nach Moskau sorgte heute
morgen für Aufsehen eine russische
Regierungsmaschine war am Berliner
Flughafen gelandet und kurz darauf
wieder abzuheben eigentlich ist der
deutsche Luftraum für russische
Flugzeuge aber gesperrt inzwischen gibt
es aber eine Erklärung für diese
Ausnahmegenehmigung keins das Auswärtige
Amt macht keine Angaben dazu wer an Bord
war allerdings wurde bestätigt dass ein
russischer Sonderflug im Zusammenhang
stehen mit Gesprächen zwischen
Deutschland und Russland über Fragen der
personellen Besetzung der jeweiligen
diplomatischen Vertretungen das
russische Außenministerium war auf
Deutschland Zitat massenausweisungen von
Russen vor die antiplomatischen
Vertretungen in Deutschland tätig waren
und teilte mit es würden als Reaktion
mehr als 20 deutsche Diplomaten
ausgewiesen
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
härtere Strafmaßnahmen sowie eine
Durchsetzung der bestehenden Sanktionen
gegen Russland gefordert in seiner am
Abend verbreiteten Videobotschaft sagte
silensky je härter die Sanktionen gegen
Russland und gegen die gesamte russische
Kriegswirtschaft sind desto schneller
wäre der Krieg enden die schwersten
Schlachten gäbe es aktuell weiter in der
Region Donezk darunter in bachmut Bilder
von dort veröffentlichte das russische
Staatsfernsehen russland hat nach
eigenen Angaben drei weitere Bezirke von
bachmut eingenommen für die geplante
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine kündigte
Präsident selenski den Aufbau neuer
Militäreinheiten an
die designierte Spitzenkandidatin der
FDP für die Europawahl 2024 Strack
Zimmermann hat eine europäische
Sicherheitspolitik und mehr Deutsche
führungsbereitschaft angemahnt wenn man
nicht gemeinsam europäisch ticke werde
man auch diesen Kontinent nicht wirklich
schützen können sagte sie auf dem
Parteitag der liberal in Berlin dort
ging es heute auch um die kursbestimmung
der FDP Generalsekretär chiasaray
forderte eine Fitnesskur für den
Standort Deutschland es brauche eine
Agenda des Aufbruchs die Delegierten
verabschiedeten dazu auch einen
Leitantrag des Bundesvorstands
die Gewerkschaft verdi hat für Montag
das luftsicherheitspersonal am
Hauptstadtflughafen BER zu einem
Warnstreik aufgerufen es werde an diesem
Tag keine Staats von Passagierflügen
geben teilte der Flughafenbetreiber mit
auch Ankünfte können betroffen sein die
Gewerkschaft fordert unter anderem
höhere Zuschläge für Wochenend und
feiertagsarbeit
auf dem Königsstuhl stehen auf
Kreidefelsen und Ostsee schauen dafür
reisen Touristen seit Jahrhunderten nach
Rügen auch wenn man in der Hochsaison
Schlange stehen musste zack schnell ein
Foto und der nächste bitte was dann die
Caspar David friedrich-mäßige Romantik
etwas einschränkt aber der Ausblick ist
halt auch wirklich toll und soll nun
noch spektakulärer werden dank des neuen
Skywalks der über den Kreidefelsen führt
heute war Eröffnung des neuen königswegs
die
schroffenfelsformationen erheben sich
spektakulär an der Ostküste der Insel
das mächtige Nadelöhr aus Stahl schiebt
sich über die Abbruchkante aufgehängt
mit Stahlseilen an einem Mast der
Skywalk zehn Jahre Planung zwei Jahre
Bauzeit 11,3 Millionen Euro teuer
jahrhunderte lang war der höchste
Kreidefelsen Deutschlands begehbar damit
ist jetzt Schluss der Grund Erosion der
Kalkstein bröckelt die Steilküste zieht
sich zurück jedes Jahr ein paar
Zentimeter Ingenieur Axel Winkel hat den
Bau überwacht
in dem Problembereich auch warum diese
Plattform eigentlich auch erforderlich
wurde ganz genau hier ist eigentlich der
der größte die größte Erosion des
Kreidefelsen hier vorhanden und diese
Treppenbreite wurde im letzten September
wurde der Königstuhl gesperrt betreten
verboten für immer um ihm dennoch
nahezukommen und diese Lösung ein
schweben Rundweg 185 Meter lang
Architektur und Natur eng beieinander
und doch auf Distanz
im Sommer 2021 beginnen die Bauarbeiten
auf sensible im Terrain im sicheren
Abstand zum bröckelten Königstuhl werden
im massiven Gestein Profile 50 Meter
tief verankert ein Stahlturm errichtet
daran die Plattform aufgehängt und in
Position gebracht
Mark Ehlers ist Chef des
nationalparkzentrums Betreiber der
Anlage mehrfach kam es zu Verzögerungen
beim Bau alles wurde viel teurer doch am
Ende ist für ihn der Skywalk ein großer
Wurf also schon beeindruckendes Bauwerk
aber auch anmutig und doch sehr
zurückhaltend dafür dass es eben solche
Dimension hatte ich meine wir tragen
hier 90 Meter aus der Mast ist über 40 m
hoch und trotzdem überragt er die
umgebenden buchen nur minimal also viel
zurückhaltender kann man einen Bauwerk
dieser Dimension hier nicht einfügen der
Königstuhl liegt mitten im Nationalpark
Jasmund die Naturschützer können mit dem
Projekt leben wir konzentrieren die
Besucher hier den versuchen Sie nicht
selbstständig irgendwo an die Küste zu
kommen wo es vielleicht richtig
gefährlich ist und diese Philosophie
geht seit vielen Jahren auf und wir
müssen diesen Punkt auch erlebbar halten
und deswegen dieses Bauwerk die
Eröffnung heute war zugleich der erste
Test Besucher kamen reichlich der
Skywalk könnte ein Erfolg werden es war
so im ersten
wunderbare Ausblick wunderbare
Konstruktion es wackelt so ein bisschen
aber man fühlt sich trotzdem sicher
die Konstrukteure versichern so wie sie
ihren Skywalk am Königstuhl gebaut haben
hält der 100 Jahre mindestens
die Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 13 21 26 34
41 48 Superzahl 7 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 556 und noch die
Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es im
Nordwesten zunächst viel Sonnenschein
später ziehen Schauer auf an den Alpen
und im Osten sind auch Gewitter dabei
die Temperatur erreicht 15 bis 20 Grad
in den nächsten Tagen bleibt es
überwiegend nass dazu gehen die
Temperaturen wieder spürbar zurück
maximal 6 bis 17 Grad
das war es von uns gleich geht's mit dem
Aktuellen Sportstudio weiter und danach
so gegen einen Uhr gibt es dann die
nächste heute Express und uns morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]